وهو يتجول في شوارع مدينته يسترجع كامله
من الحرب وذلك عبر بعضا من ابرز الرسوماته
على جدران خارجي
فجوه زمنيه تحدث فيها كل هذه الفضاء ثم
تختفي
كتيبه المتطوعين التي ينتمي اليها لكن
جمله لا يحمل السلاح بل ريشه الرسمه
فيحاول ان يحول اثار القنابل والصواريخ
الى اعمال فنيه
رايت هذه الاثار على الشارع ووجدتها تشبه
كثيرا الزهور فصنعت منها سلسله مع شعارات
مختلفه فاصبحت لدينا هذه الازهار هنا
الغارات لم تترك اثارها في شوارع خارجي
فقط بل في النفوس ايضا
فترات القصف ثم استيقظ ليلا على صوت
الغارات وفي الصباح
نزل حال فتره الى غرب اوكرانيا ثم عاد الى
مسقط راسه في ايار مايو الماضي كي يحول
المدينه الى متحف في الهواء الطلق لتكريم
المقاومه الاوكرانيه
سبونج بوب
لقد استقبلوهم بالفعل لكن ليس بالازهار
بالزجاجات الملوث
ا من قضايا الحرب التي حولها الى اعمال
ستباع في مازادات بالاموال سيقدم مركبه
مصفحه للجيش قيمتها 89,000 يورو لكن اضافه
الى دعم المقاومه الرسم بالنسبه اليه هو
وسيله للتعبير عن مشاعره
الخميس لايك بالنسبه لي الرسم يضاهي ساعات
من التامل كل يوم
اولهما تاسيس مركز لاعاده تاهيل الجنود
الذين يعانون من اثار الحرب
[موسيقى]
والاحتلال الروسي لاراضي بلاده يريد جمله